egos clash when Jack Black and the
rocker in the same space you would think
that egos would collide but it was
nothing could be further from the truth
Dwayne the rock Johnson and I shared a
magical bond we didn't need words we
just exchanged an energy eye contact
turned into a soul-searching industrial
complex of exchange I don't know I
thought we had a good chemistry yeah
it's it's it's just chemistry chemistry
okay kind of sounds like you wouldn't
talk - yeah his trailer was locked
whenever you went to see you
oh we're connecting don't get worried I
got to ask the ladies are gonna want to
know you you've worked with them both
now on the same set who's sex your the
rock or Nick Jonas that's you can't now
that's too hard I can't make that I mean
cuz the rock obviously you've got the
musculature
you've got the powerful bearing and Nick
Jones just so darn cute and there's two
different kinds of attraction there
that's that's like Sophie's Choice I
can't make that choice that's like
that's like that's Jackie's choice too
hard
you